good morning minister
um did you get an invitation to the
wedding yesterday
no but uh i want to congratulate the
prime minister and
carrie simmons uh on tying the knot uh
and it's a a great uh
feeling uh as uh you come together and
of course
i think it's it's a wonderful thing for
both of them that they
uh have
really sort of made their their their
marriage vows to one another
um the fact that this came out of the
blue is this a kind a hint
to all couples who are waiting
uh and delaying their marriage hoping
that after june the 21st
they'll be able to invite more than 30
people was the
prime minister's uh and carrie simmons
decision to go yesterday a hint that
there's no point
june the 21st is not going to be what we
hope it was going to be
no i wouldn't extrapolate anything from
that uh
trevor on the 14th of june we will set
out
very clearly the data that we are
continuing to gather
from of step three which was on the
17th of may and then we'll share that
with the nation
as the prime minister has done in each
and every step from
step one two and three and then of
course step four
uh we continue to vaccinate at scale we
are
almost at 39 million people now with at
least one dose
and almost 25 million people with two
doses so uh
i think the important thing is to keep
going vaccinating at scale but also
share the data on the
14th of june okay as we have done in the
past to give people
the the ability then to to plan ahead
okay
we'll um interrogate just how consistent
the government has been
with that data not dates promise
in a moment but um i just want to put
you that ask you
this morning about a story that's in the
sunday times
saying that it intelligence sources
have um suggested that it's feasible
that's their word but the worldwide
pandemic
came from a chinese lab in wuhan
make sense to you and why is it taking
so long
to get to the point where we just know
it's feasible
well i think it's really important that
the who
is allowed to conduct its investigation
unencumbered into the origins of this
pandemic and that we should leave no
stone unturned
to understand why not only because of
obviously the current
pandemic that is has swept the world but
also
for future future proofing
the world's capability to deal with
pandemics and it was also really good to
see the prime minister
announced the sort of global radar uh
which we are leading the way we
we account for just under 50 of all
genome sequencing
of this virus and the setting up of a
global radar
to be able to track virus mutations
virus variants is going to be incredibly
important but the who has to be able to
conduct
its investigation unencumbered you you
you have to depend on who data and
guidance for
a lot of the things that you do in your
job do you feel comfortable depending on
an agency that's saying now it's
feasible that this came out of a
lab in wuhan but in january we're saying
that a leak
was extremely unlikely does that seem
like an
agency that you can trust well i think
the who
at every step of the way has tried to
share as much data with the world
as it is able to verify this is a very
difficult situation as we've seen
around the world not just um in the who
but of course
in our own country with our own evidence
gathering
and of course advice and in other
countries every country whether it's
singapore
or australia or new zealand or elsewhere
we've all had to
you know collect evidence and then act
upon it and i think it's only right
that the who is allowed to conduct its
investigation
unencumbered uh to be able for all of us
to understand and to deal with
this and future pandemics i i asked this
minister because
at the heart of um this week's con
discussions
have been the question whether we can
trust our authorities and
i i want to come to the uh issue of
um what dominic cummings has been saying
to us this week he took aim at the civil
service
at ministers indeed himself but his
gravest
accusation was that tens of thousands of
people
who didn't need to die perished because
of your government's
failures and because you didn't level
with the people
he said i think that the idea that any
kind of serious inquiry and lessons
learned
doesn't start until next year is
completely terrible
the families of all tens of thousands of
people who died
didn't need to die there is absolutely
no excuse for delaying the inquiry
because a lot of the reasons for why
that happened
are still in place now what he's really
saying is the most damning
aspect of his allegation is that the
failures
of the government that we can't trust
government and that the failures and
mistakes
that uh led us to this situation are
still
there how can we trust you
well i would say a couple of things on
this one is that
we will have a proper statutory inquiry
where people will come and give evidence
under oath so we've heard you know
parts of the story of course every life
lost
is a grandfather grandmother father
uncle aunt i lost my uncle to this
uh terrible virus uh because we couldn't
get him vaccinated
um in time although he was eligible for
it so i know the pain
of losing loved ones to this
virus we've also saved many lives the
public health england's data the last
recent data suggests that
almost 40 000 people have been spared
going into hospital and serious illness
because of the vaccination
program over 13 000
have not lost their life
are alive today because of the
vaccination program so i think
the right thing to do is to wait for
that inquiry in spring of 2022. let me
tell you why i think it's the right
thing
to do trevor just one one tiny thing if
you listen to
professor jonathan van tam who's working
all hours
19 hours a day seven days a week and he
literally
was pleading with the nation to say
please not now because we need to carry
on
we remain in the middle of a very
serious situation
with the coronavirus pandemic and of
course the rest of the world remains in
that situation as well
so it has to be the right thing to do is
to have
an inquiry when we can learn the lessons
and we will absolutely do that
and of course sorry we hear this point
minister we hear this point
however ministers come on programs like
this all the time
and i've heard matt hancock say this
maybe a dozen times we are learning all
the time
we are learning new things as we're
going along and we know things
that we didn't know last year now
cummings had some choice words
about ministers and their shortcomings
and he said in particular about matt
hancock
that he should have been fired at least
15 times
for putting it let's put it mildly
misleading the public
uh by claiming he had been putting a
shield around care homes last year
cummings said we were told categorically
in march that people would be tested
before they went back to care homes we
only subsequently found out
that had not happened now all the
government rhetoric was
we've put a shield around care homes and
blah blah blah coming said
it was complete nonsense quite the
opposite of putting a shield around them
we sent people back
to uh to care homes with coving now the
point here
is not whether the vaccination
program has worked whether you've tried
your best but
whether when you speak to the public you
have been clear
you have been direct you have told us
the truth and the whole
truth you have leveled with us cummings
is saying
that the one thing that you can control
which is what you say to the public
you haven't actually done straight
i don't recognize that characterization
because
i've been working for the past seven
months with
matt hancock and i can tell you that
every day
he comes into the office and he focuses
on using every resource available to us
to be able to save lives not least with
this
vaccine rollout that i've been uh
responsible for reporting
into him and into the prime minister i
think it's really important to remember
and to put a bit of context around this
trevor
you know in the either storm of a
pandemic
early last year we only had the
capability to conduct about 2 000 tests
a day you know our diagnostics
capability in the uk
was almost non-existent today
last week last seven days we conducted
over six million tests so to say that
you know hindsight is a wonderful thing
but to say that you know
for some reason we haven't been leveling
with people i think is
wrong and is mistaken at every stage
matt hancock used every resource
available to him to do his
best possible job for the people that he
needed to protect
this is not hindsight let's deal with a
question i actually asked you nobody's
contesting
whether ministers worked hard whether
you tried to do your best
the question was whether you told us
the truth that you knew it now the
last summer a consultant geriatrician
at told the british medical journal
journaled this before any instruction
from nhs england
emergency legislation or government cash
injections
acute hospitals around the country were
busy implementing
escalation plans to prevent hospitals
from being swamped
many of us were in good faith and for
understandable reasons
in that early pandemic context sending
people to care homes
with or without covet 19 testings
look this is a senior consultant in a
big london hospital
all he's saying is that government had a
difficult choice to make
and you decided the more important thing
to do is to protect hospitals
uh even if that meant some risk to care
homes why can't you just say
you had a hard choice to make and you
made a brave
call why can't you just say that
well i i think what i was trying to say
to you is
exactly um the situation that
as we found ourselves in early last year
when we entered this pandemic we could
only conduct about 2 000 tests
a day and you had to make sure that you
test the front line as well as those
who are being discharged into care homes
and on the 15th of april when
that decision was made and shared with
the country and
with the system that people will be
tested
the nhs then operationalized that and we
grew testing capacity and that target of
100 000
i think was equally important because
actually setting targets in government
is a good thing as i have discovered
that there was and then
and then we continued to expand it
trevor so so i don't
think minister yeah but you must have
known sorry there was
some risk why can't you just say
we knew that but we had a big decision
to make
and we decided making sure that the nhs
was not overwhelmed was the priority
but but both were the priorities trevor
that's the whole thing what i'm trying
to explain to you is
both things were the priority but we
know hindsight is a wonderful thing you
work with the resources you have you do
your best
with whatever resource you have
available to you at the time
as well as then investing and growing it
so if you start
a pandemic with the ability to only
conduct 2 000
tests a day you quite rightly say to
yourself how am i going to get to a
place
where i can do over 6 million tests in
seven days which is what we've just
delivered this past seven days
that is the whole point is you grow
we've begun this pandemic
only able to manufacture two percent of
our ppe we now manufacture
about 70 percent of rpp diagnostics
was similar 2000 and now as i say the
capability to do oh probably over a
million a day
of tests so i don't i don't see these
things
as being a trade-off you have to do
both things but you do them with the
resources that are available to you at
the time
it really wasn't what anybody said at
the time and it sounds a little bit like
boris johnson cakism that
you want it both ways but let's just
deal with some of your own
responsibilities right
now minister um you personally see
overseen the great success of this
administration
50 million vaccine vaccination doses
third of population you've talked about
it
earlier in this conversation we've got a
lot of stocks we've got machinery
why aren't you keeping up the pace and
giving jobs to children as recommended
by the european medical agency
well because first of all our own
regulator has not yet
approved giving vaccines to children
you have to make sure the vaccines are
incredibly safe before
you give them to children we've seen the
pfizer
biontic vaccine being approved by the
u.s regulator and the canadian
regulator for 12 to 15 year olds um the
mhra our own independent regulator and
of course the joint committee on
vaccination immunization we'll have to
look
very carefully at this because of course
you're not vaccinating children
some obviously get infected and get long
covered but on the whole you're
vaccinated to protect their families and
their communities
and the country so vaccines as chris
whittier say
have to be incredibly safe before you
administer
children but we will be ready the
infrastructure we've built
allows us the the ability to deploy
vaccines for 12 to 15 year olds
as well as of course planning for the
boost in the autumn
and the flu vaccination campaign so
the infrastructure's there but of course
the clinicians have to make that final
decision
there is um the reports today that you
want to make
potentially vaccination compulsory for
nhs
staff to make sure that you crack down
on the spread of the virus in hospitals
for some people that makes sense is that
what's going to happen
so we've recently consulted on the
social care front line staff uh in terms
of um duty of care to those
who are most vulnerable you and i've
been talking about the residents
of care homes who were by the way put at
the top of the list
of the vaccination program and that duty
of care
we've been consulting on in terms of
condition of deployment into social care
i think it's only right that we look at
the health care system as well
we've been talk you and i have been
talking about infections um
out of hospital it's absolutely the
right thing it would be incumbent on
any responsible government to have the
debate to have the
to do the thinking as to how we go about
protecting the most vulnerable
by making make sure that those who look
after them are vaccinated
there is precedent for this obviously
surgeons get vaccinated for
hepatitis b so it's something that we
are absolutely thinking about
so it's possible let me just ask you one
last question minister thank you for
your
time um you've had to depend
on the what people call this the
whitehall machine
civil service public health england and
so on
one of the issues that emerged out of
cummings his testimony
is his pretty dusty opinion
of the level of delivery and the
capability
of the civil service in a crisis
what do you say to cummings and indeed
other people who've been saying this
week
that with the best will in the world a
lot of clever people in our civil
service
it literally is not up to snuff not
modern enough
not capable and that actually we need to
take some urgent action
to get that machine into the 21st
century
i would respectfully disagree
and i tell you for why and i've been
doing this job now for
seven months and i you know wished that
dominick cummings
was because he wasn't involved in the
vaccination program
but i wished he was there because he
would see the capability of the civil
service whether it be maddie mcternan
who's my senior
responsible officer on vaccine supply
ruth todd who works with her steve glass
or
emily lawson the brilliant senior
responsible officer
at the nhs doing the deployment he would
have seen the civil service
at its best coming together with our
armed forces
with of course the nhs family doctors
nurses
uh the gps the pharmacists all coming
together
with the private sector of course and
local government local government's been
an incredibly integral part of this
he would have seen a machinery of
government coming together with
extraordinary talent in the civil
service
delivering this program and i if if he'd
been there
i think he would have maybe possibly had
a different point of view
in front of the committee you said uh
over the last seven months the civil
service had its best
uh delivers um but the problem is it's
probably not all
always at its best let me quote you what
uh mr cummings had to say on all of this
we all should be asking and you guys in
the political parties need to ask
yourselves
um what is it about your parties that
give choices like johnson and corbyn
and we have to ask what is it about
whitehall
that promotes so many people who are
completely
out of their depth do you have no
uh sympathy with that view
well all i can say to you and we all
fall back on the experiences that we
have
the experience of being the vaccine's
deployment minister
i don't recognize that point of view
there are extraordinary talent people
in the civil service doing an incredible
job and i can tell you because i came
out of the private sector
into politics as you know trevor you and
i go back a long way i would hire all of
them in a heartbeat they are
amazing people doing amazing work
working all hours and delivering
operationally competent people and as i
say if dominic cummings had been
uh you know involved in the vaccination
program i suspect you may have changed
his mind
on that view that he gave the committee
minister thank you very much for your
time this morning